these protests were smaller than before
and the mood was very different the riot
police out in large numbers
but in moscow mostly they let the people
far be out in the russian capital than
the 100 000 who'd signed up
and most were young but with strong
convictions
we can't do anything for him to get out
of the prison
but we can't do something for him not to
die
concerned too not just about navalny's
health but about the latest threats to
his foundation
the fbk the fbk is going to be labeled
an extremist organization which pretty
much equals everyone around here
to terrorists and that's absolutely
terrible because
i mean the russian government isn't
pretending to be a democracy anymore
it's just
a de facto kleptocratic police
dictatorship yulia alexey navalny's
wife showed up as she always does with
his brother oleg
this time both allowed to go free
alexei navalny always wanted to have his
demonstrations held here in front of the
kremlin
and he was never authorized to do so and
as he lies
on hunger strike in a prison hospital
his supporters have managed to make it
happen
there were more than a thousand arrests
across russia though
tougher police measures in st petersburg
especially and people rallied in cities
across
every russian time zone as vladivostok
in the far east took to the streets
president putin delivered his state of
the nation address
mostly focused on domestic affairs but
with this message
for the wider world
we really don't want to burn bridges but
if some mistake our good intentions for
indifference
or weakness and intent to burn or even
blow up those bridges themselves
russia's response will be asymmetrical
quick
and tough but as expected he made no
mention of the man these people came out
for
the crowd seemed cheerful grateful to
all who'd shown up
a simple message here thank you for
coming
[Music]
diana mcnay sky news